هالاند التاريخيه يتفوق على صلاح ادراجوس
موبيلي في القاموس البرتغالي ونجم الجولف
يحطم سيارتها احلامه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه الرياضات اهلا بكم
فوز مهم حققه فريق مانشستر سيتي امام
ارسنال لكن غرفه ملابس
شهدت احتفالات كبيره بين اللاعبين شاركوها
مع متابعيهم على السوشيال ميديا ان الوجيه
هالاند
برناردو سيلفا وكتب قائلا ساتبعك اينما
ذهبت فيما شارك جاكريليج ستوري مع متابعه
ضمه الثنائي البرتغالي روبين
رقم محمد صلاح كافضل هداف في موسم واحد لم
يصمد اكثر من خمس سنوات قبل ان يحتمه
ايرلينغ هالاند مهاجمه مانشستر سيتي الذي
احرز ثلاثه 33 هدفا اخرهم كان امام نادي
ارسنال ويملك النرويجي فرصه للابتعاد اكثر
عن رقم النجم المصري حيث تتبقى 7 مباريات
لمانشستر سيتي في مسابقه الدوري وقد يتخطى
حاجز الاربعين هدفا بسهوله
ادرج اسمه اسطوره البرازيل بيليه في قاموس
الاسماء الشائعه للغه البرتغاليه واصبحت
كلمه بيليه في البرتغاليه مرادفه
للاستثنائي او المتميز هذه الاضافه هي
نتيجه لحمله مشتركه اطلقتها مؤسسه بيليه
في شهر ابريل الحالي بالشراكه مع نادي
سانتوس ولا يزال يكرم الى الان في
البرازيل عبر وقوف في دقيقه صمت في جميع
مباريات الدوري البرازيلي والمباريات
القاريه للانديه اللاتينيه
في خبرنا الاخير تعرض نجم الجولف الامريكي
باتل كريد لحادث سير تحطمت على اثري سياره
الخارقه من نوع قرشي 911
هذه السياره المميزه والتي تعد اصدارا
محدودا صنع منها 500 نسخه فقط وسعرها
يتجاوز 400 الف يورو لكن وبعد هذا الحادث
وضعت على لائحه موقع كوبرت الامريكي
للمزادات المختص في بيع السيارات التي
تعرضت للحوادث
[موسيقى]